gut sie miteinander und herzliche grüße
jury wir begrüßen euch heute aus zürich
in der schweiz vor kurzem haben wir
schon videos gemacht dazu wie ähnlich
deutsch und niederländisch
beziehungsweise dänisch sind und viele
fragen erreichen uns auch zum
schweizerdeutsch und da hat uns vor
kurzem die halo deutsch schule hier in
zürich eingeladen mal videos zum thema
schweizer recht zu machen und wir haben
gesagt klar wir kommen vorbei hier sind
wir mit claudia claudia woher kommst du
ich komme aus zürich und welchen dialekt
sprichst du ich spreche den klassischen
sagen wir hier zürcher dialekt das heißt
wir zeigen euch mal in diesem video wie
ähnlich oder auch wie unähnlich
hochdeutsch und schweizerisch sind
schweizerdeutsch ist das denn eigene
sprache oder nicht jesus eigentlich wir
sagen ja immer dass das ein dialekt ist
weil es das passiert hier wirklich auf
ein hochdeutsches auch in der schule
lernt man zuerst hochdeutsch im
kindergarten auch ganz viele filme
gucken wir auf hochdeutsch das ist
eigentlich die sprache die man lernt das
ist sehr interessant für uns weil ihr
sprecht zwar auch hochdeutsch und
versteht hochdeutsch
umgekehrt ist das aber nicht so ein
deutscher versteht in der schweiz ganz
oft fast gar nichts und so geht das auch
vielen von euch die deutsch lernen und
dann in die schweiz kommen oder
vielleicht hier arbeiten und plötzlich
ganz wenig verstehen deswegen wollen wir
euch heute mal zeigen wie ähnlich oder
unähnlich die beiden sprachen sind und
am ende gibt es auch noch einen test wo
iranischen ich mal testen müssen wie
viel wir eigentlich verstehen vom
schweizerdeutsch bis das reizt ich bin
bereit ich freue mich drauf
guten tag gerierte hallo ich spreche
hochdeutsch
ich rede schweizerdeutsch das haus zu
fuß die straße straße das fahrrad das
auto das auto der mülleimer
der rebell der gehweg ist rot war das
ist ein französisches wort ja genau das
wird abgeleitet aus dem französisch
heißt hochdeutsch hat ja auch schon
viele französischen einflüsse aber
schreibt es der deutsche wahrscheinlich
noch mehr genau weil sie auch einen
französischen teil in der schweiz gibt
richtig sowie das velo rufen kommt auch
von loewe loe
wie geht's dir gorz wohin gehst du wohin
ich gehe nach unten
ich glaube ich nehme den zug ich
erhoffte zug
ruft mich an wenn du angekommen bist mit
mir wenn du auch hobbys
er versteht nicht was total laufen
[Gelächter]
hast du dein portemonnaie dabei hat die
sportmanager b ich muss zur arbeit
moskau hoffe ich habe heute ein brötchen
mit marmelade gefrühstückt die hüte svec
klinikum wismar genau gar nichts
verstehen als aber tatsächlich weg wie
würde man in süddeutschland geschlecht
zu erwecken oder er konnte zum morgen
frühstücken ist morgens morgen hart
morgen
wahnsinn woher kommen sie vorwoche mit
sie kommen wir müssen uns beeilen rum
interessieren warum interessieren
sehr schön oder das klingt ja jetzt auch
schon was wir richtig schweizer dass
sein kompliment pressefest pressen
das macht man in deutschland nur bei der
geburt
[Gelächter]
schau mal luke morgen lockt das ist wie
luck das englische glamour club nur
normal
hör mir zu los mehr zu ich hätte gerne
einen kaffee gern im café janosch hat
uns gebeten einsatz speziell für ihn zu
sprechen und der geht so was guckst du
mich so an
hast du ein problem was laut szabo
falsches problem lange freut sich hinter
der kamera kanal richtig auf der straße
hier stunk machen wir müssen noch
kartoffeln kaufen
woher der fluss aus essen die schweizer
auch so gerne kartoffeln ja deutschen
dass es auch so wir ziehen um mehr
zyklen was hast du heute abend gegessen
was hast du zum nachkauf gehen wir aus
kinos kam
wir gehen ausgang die den ausgang genau
oder wahrscheinlich einfach rausgehen
wir machen ausgang ausgang ist in
deutsch in hochdeutsch wenn man aus dem
gefängnis für einen tag raus darf und
kann wieder zurück
rathmann ausgang bei euch ist was der
straße quasi geatmet genau wenn man kurz
raus darf hat mal ausgegangen
ich trinke leitungswasser ich bringe
horne war es claudia treffen wir uns in
der kneipe wo gern gori gern mehr traf
ich trinke ein bier in einer kneipe ich
trink riskiere ich trinke sbirinda bei
cs glaube ich der wichtigste satz ist
ähnliche brauche ich trinke spielen
dabei wo ist mein handy wo ich mich nach
telgte
nachteil das war als wirklich früher als
man so dass zum ersten mal die handys
hatte war swisscom in telekom-anbieter
der hat das sogenannt und der anleger
hieß nadja das war die swiss kommen aber
die haben dieses portabler telefon so
bezeichnet und deshalb kommt das daher
dass deutsche worte ist auch nicht
besser wir haben es handy genannt und
das ja gar kein englisches wort
ich telefoniere mit meinem helm ich gehe
schlafen
ich danke schlafe ich ging gut
ich glaube ja das ist immer dieses ich
gehe sagt man in der innerschweiz immer
ich gange ich gehe aber ich gehe
schwimmen ich kongo spülgang bier
trinken in der wald sich gm bier trinkt
mich gang go s bier trinken ich ganz
groß bier trinken dabei aber das nicht
werde immer besser ist richtig gut
ich habe schluckauf
ich habe da hits kiki der hitze das
macht sinn
ja dieses schluckauf schluck schlucken
ist
grund waren auch erst so ist sehr
deutlich schlug auch auf also das waren
unsere wörter vielleicht habt ihr jetzt
gehört wie unterschiedlich hoch deutsch
und schweizerdeutsch klingt also
teilweise sehr unterschiedlich was mich
jetzt interessiert ist ihr lernt ja aber
schon hochdeutsch in der schule und wo
verwendet ihr denn hochdeutsch in der
schweiz also es ist schon vor allem ist
es die die schriftsprache also hier in
der schweiz genauso die dialekt sprechen
klar da spricht man dialekt und es ist
wirklich sich ausdrücken
es hat auch was formelles aber auch
natürlich auch in der schule aufsätze
oder geschichten oder autoren ist
natürlich alles in der schriftsprache
also hochdeutsch meine ich das heißt
schriftlich benutzt ihr den dialekt gar
nicht oder wo schreibt in den dialekt
doch dialekt schreibt man so unter
freunden das ist dann sehr informell
also whatsapp nachricht oder so zum
beispiel schreibt man dann auch
schweizerdeutsch schwyzerdütsch aber da
kennt man die leute das ist schon sehr
informell die mann der aus dem ausland
kommt in die schweiz sieht würdest du
auch empfehlen hochdeutsch zu lernen
sowieso aber auch hochdeutsch zu
sprechen einfach auf der straße das
heißt man wird verstanden und kann sich
eigentlich dann auch in hochdeutsch
ausdrücken ja man wird sowieso
verstanden weil eben das lernt man das
lernt man in der schule und ich empfehle
genau das will ich zuerst einfach die
hochdeutsche sprache zu lernen auch auch
die ganze grammatik um dann darauf
aufbauen weil ich denke wenn man länger
hier lebt ist es kann man dann
schweizerdeutsch verstehen vielleicht
auch ein paar wörter annehmen aber die
basis finde ich muss hochdeutsch sein
weil sonst kriegst du so ganz komische
konstrukte die dann gar nicht stimmen
ein guter tipp für alle weil schreiner
schon viele leute die in die schweiz
sehen und die hochdeutsch lernen oder
gelernt haben und dann hier völlig
überfordert sind
weil man steht versteht ja eben
wenn man hochdeutsch kann nicht
unbedingt schweizerdeutsch und das geht
mir übrigens auch so und wir machen
jetzt nämlich einen test und mal zu
sehen damit ihr auch seht wie schwierig
das eigentlich ist das heißt du
verstehst schweizerin in deutschland
alles umgekehrt ist es überhaupt nicht
so und ich habe claudia gebeten sich
eine kleine geschichte auszudenken und
mir das mal in schweizerdeutsch zu
erzählen und ich muss verstehen worum es
geht er hat noch schnell die sechs
stücke hat begonnen und dann ist und
dann kurz zentrum gegangen hat früher
ihr blick kaufte ich nachher zur tour
packt und hat man müsse gut trainiere
gang hat dann am schluss nahe die
bereits dunkel
ok also das waren aber viele
informationen das konnte ich ja gar
nicht waren drei situationen und wir
machen soll in kürze machen machen noch
einmal und dann habe ich
er hat namen wie solostück und mir schon
ganz gut sind sich auf zentrum gegangen
hat früher blick kräftig zurück hat
taktisch gut trainiere gegangen und im
plus notieren ok also jemand musste in
die post gehen und und dann ist er aber
in einem zentrum gegangen und dann war
er wieder zu hause hat seine sachen
gepackt ist trainieren und es später
hatte er noch in der kneipe ein bier
getrunken sehr schön mit dieser betrag
reiche es dieses wort kennt auch sonst
hätte es mehr arten kleinen vorsprung
er kannte das ja genau das war es und
gepushte gar heißt nicht auf die post
oder zur post sondern einkaufen gehen
davon ist timo staiger und am einkaufen
geht und genau dieser karotten dann muss
er ins zentrums einkaufszentrum centrum
verstanden ja ok jan stetzer auch noch
mal testen also an llanos die hand mit
einem 3 abgemacht und hat ein bisschen
[Musik]
nach es immer kassen und billig leider
gar nichts noch mal langsam ganz langsam
also der ja nun schon die die hand
abgemachte genommen nachher hammer weil
eine pistole gegangen sind der kasse
gegangen
und die bietet intersky also wir haben
untereinander ausgemacht dass wir uns
irgendwo treffen und danach sind wir in
eine kasse gegangen und haben dort
tickets gekauft
[Gelächter]
ich habe gesagt wir haben ca um 15 uhr
haben wir abgemacht dann sehen wir zur
kasse gegangen und wollten tickets
kaufen aber die waren schon ausverkauft
okay war gar nichts
ok also leute übung macht den meister
nicht
ja wir hoffen ihr habt jetzt einen
eindruck bekommen wie ähnlich oder
unendlich hoch deutsch und
schweizerdeutsch sind danke claudia dass
du dabei warst sehr sehr gerne das hat
richtig spaß gemacht mit euch zusammen
und danke auch an die schule an der du
arbeitest die halo deutsche schule in
zürich in dieser schule sind wir nämlich
gerade
und die haben uns eingeladen um
verschiedene videos zusammen zu drehen
das ist jetzt eins davon werden noch
weitere videos gedreht und diese schule
hat auch einen youtube kanal der sehr
populär ist dort gibt es nämlich dialoge
vor allem für anfänger zu sehen und zwar
im hochdeutschen er unterrichtet hoch
kenobi und richten hochdeutsch dem was
ich vorhin schon gesagt habe dass das
einfach die basis ist weil ja
schwyzerdütsch sagen wir immer ist halt
einfach ein dialekt also wenn ihr in
zürich seid könnt ihr euch die schule
mal ansehen hallo deutsch schule und
hier unten verlinken wir auch den kanal
bzw hier
und dann könnt ihr mal den kanal
auschecken der halle deutsche schule
danke fürs zu sehen und danke dass du
damals dabei
düster